Hey, I'm Chad and in this video, we're
going to unpack how to say the right things
in a conversation. And in particular, I'm
going to share 3 key ideas on how to say
the right things in a conversation every time. By
the end of this video, you are going to feel like
at the end of every conversation and the people
you're in conversation with are going to feel like
you just said the right things at the right time
for the right context. And so, it doesn't matter
if you're in a funny conversation with a friend
or a serious conversation with a family member.
Or a really intense conversation with a
co-worker. This video will share 3 key
ideas that will help you say the right things
in conversation every time. Let's get into it.
One time I was at a restaurant with my wife and
Kate and 2 friends and I got up to go to the
bathroom and somehow I bumped into somebody.
I don't remember exactly how this was. It was
outside the bathroom. I bumped into somebody.
His name was Greg. He was with 3 other people.
Their names were Amy, Susan, and Cindy. And
about an hour later, we had finished our meal
everything was cool. And we walked back and I just
said, "Hey, Greg. Hey, Susan. Hey, Cindy. Hey,
Amy." And Greg stopped me and was like, "How'd
you do that?" And then he didn't wait for me to
answer the question. And then he said... And he
just started answering his own question and said,
"Actually, I know exactly how you remembered our
names." I guess Greg was a construction worker
and he went on to tell me this story about a guy
named Dominic who he was doing a project on his
house for this multi-multi-millionaire. And every
single morning when Dominic would leave the house
he would say hi to over 20 people who were
working on his house. There was even one
time where someone was taking out the trash and
Dominic said hi by name to every single person as
he walked to his car. And one day Greg stopped
Dominic and asked him and said, "Dude, how in
the world? You've got to tell me how do you do
that?" And Dominic looked at him straight in the
face and says, "You know why you don't remember
names? Because you don't care enough." I was like
boom! I think there are other reasons may be that
you remember names. But the point is in order for
these 3 key ideas that I'm going to share on
how to say the right things in conversation,
you have to actually care about the people you're
talking to. You can't fudge this. You can't
manufacture and just say the right things.
Because part of the idea of saying the right
things in conversation is being as authentic
as possible in that conversation. And so, if
you're putting on some sort of face and trying to
be something or trying to do something else, it's
not going to click or resonate with that person.
And so, in order for these to work, you've got to
care as Dominic said he did. The idea number one
is reflectively listen. Reflective listening is
an extremely simple and underutilized tool. But
it's phenomenally useful because it allows you
to just hold up a mirror to the other person and
reflect back what they're saying. And so, if you
want to say the right things in conversation,
don't try to come up with that yourself.
Use the person's words, the person's sentiment,
etc. You can check out this other video with
a whole breakdown of four different levels
of reflective listening and how to do them.
But in this video, just the short bit is hear what
somebody's saying, not just their words but the
music behind the words, the sentiment, what you're
noticing, what you're observing and just reflect
that back. You can reflect it back verbatim what
they said or simply translate what they said
into your own words and feed it back to them.
It is a phenomenal what happens in our brains
when we're fed back words or ideas that we
shared but didn't even really process until
somebody spoke them back to us. In the same way
that you don't know that you have a booger or a
raisin in your tooth until you walk into a mirror
and you see that for yourself. And when you gain
that awareness of what you're saying and what
you're doing, it's oftentimes the exact right
thing to happen in a conversation. Key idea
number two is turn assumptions into questions,
right? Assumptions are not fundamentally bad. They
are so natural. It's really useful that we make
assumptions oftentimes. But the key to saying the
right thing in conversation is to not act on those
assumptions or speak as if those assumptions were
true. So, to say the right thing in a conversation
if you do have an assumption, recognize that
an assumption is just a story that you have
and then turn that assumption into a
question not rooted in any judgment and
ask it. Sometimes when you're trying to figure
out the right thing to say in a conversation,
it's a question to unpack and further dive into
the conversation. When you're thinking about
how to say the right thing in a conversation, you
don't want to be really concerned with what you're
saying out of this device. You want to be more
concerned with how you're using these 2 appendages
on the side of your head and being deliberate
in the questions that you're asking. Because
people are rarely asked questions based on what
they've just said. So, often in conversation,
it goes sentence ends in a period; sentence it
ends in a period; sentence ends in a period. When
we break that mold and somebody says a sentence
that ends in a period and we fire back a question,
it feels great. Right? I haven't met a single
person on the planet that doesn't want to be
seen heard and understood at some level. So,
it's really, really phenomenal to be able to
be asked about what we've just shared. The
third key idea here is to master empathy.
The most common metaphor for empathy is standing
in somebody else's shoes. I would say and my
co-author Will would also say that empathy... oh
that's really awkward. Empathy is not standing in
somebody else's shoes. Empathy is putting
one of your feet into that person's shoes
but keeping one foot grounded in your own reality.
Because if you have both of your feet in both of
those person's shoes, I would argue that that
is sympathy. You've you're totally lost in their
reality and you can't actually know the right
things to say in a conversation. And so, that's
what happens when we hear something sad happen for
somebody and you get that like that like pitiful,
like it doesn't really make you feel better. It's
kind of it almost just like spirals, the sadness,
I would say that that's sympathy. Whereas if
you're able to be empathetic and have really
try to see the world from their perspective.
And I would say a really practical way to
make empathy happen is to describe the world
as they see it. When you describe the world as
they see it, right? That might be rooted in some
of your assumptions but it also, that person is
feeling like you're attempting to understand
them in a really empathetic way as opposed to
knowing how they feel because you have both of
your feet in their shoes at the exact same time.
I exist on the planet to gently eradicate small
talk and create conversations that matter. And so,
a lot of the stuff that we've created is
available. If you want the paper version or
the actual paper that products you can get that.
But a lot of stuff's available for free below
because I would much rather live in a world filled
with wonderful conversations, filled with empathy
and reflective listening and meaningful dialogue
as opposed to screaming yelling and judgment.
If you liked this video, you will super love the 2
videos here. But more so you'll love a lot of the
free tools resources that we have linked below.
Hope you enjoyed this video. Have an awesome day.